men in predatory reproductive mode
leave paternally imprinted genes in
favor of embryonic development
is predatory mode genetically determined
what genes will mend with predatory
inheritance but
using investment strategy leave
how can jeans know the dad's intent in
the moment of the act does dad even know
thanks for all love you both keep it up
so this is from echo this is in response
to you you know immediately
um i think it was in the last q a
we were talking about um genomic
imprinting and the idea
that uh a a baby
um is a baby's genome
actually keeps track keeps track as if
it's conscious which of course it's not
of which parent various copies of the
genes came from and that maternally
imprinted genes for instance
tend to put the brakes on excess pulling
of resources
from mom and making the head too big
before birth whereas paternally
imprinted jeans
um tend to try to pull more resources
from mom
and you had specifically been talking
about mating system perhaps being a
mitigating factor here and the question
here is well how
how are the the genes that might be
paternally imprinted
going to keep track of or know what you
know what kind of mating system data is
in
um well the answer to that might be
things like um you know keeping track of
different kinds of sperm that are
showing up in
in the mom but um also you know how do
like regardless of what kind of mating
system
um in general like what about the
individual
man and his intentions how how could a
paternally imprinted gene possibly know
well i mean look so there's a question
about what we know
and i don't know the answer to the
question about how it's done but
i do want to correct one thing okay i am
somewhat dubious
that head size would be downstream
of uh a imprinted gene
because the baby in question that is to
say the offspring of the male has every
interest in the mother surviving birth
because it is very unlikely to survive
if the mother dies in childbirth
yeah so i i don't think i made that up
but i don't have the reference
i'm just saying it could be but there's
going to have to be some sort of subtle
logic to make that
work but in general the logic is
that a uh a father's genes if a father
is not sticking with the mother in other
words if this is the only offspring
of his that she is going to bear then
his interest in her distributing her
resources across her entire brood
is lower right right so anyway there's a
lot of really
important stuff downstream from that
logic and that logic is very robust
right but to what degree
can social system and mating system
actually
can genomic imprinting actually be
informed
by the mating system in which the
players live right and so this is why i
want to say
what we need is a proof of concept right
we need a demonstration that something
mechanistic can do the job
yeah rather than a demonstration of
what it is that does the job right so
what i would argue is
for example there are
a uh courting
is a ritual enforced by
females to make sure males are actually
interested in commitment that is to say
if it takes uh months to
end up engaging in reproductive behavior
with somebody
that's a that's a long con and a very
expensive one
for a male to engage in if he's just
going to flee
right whereas it's a test not just of
intention but of actual stability like
even if you really want to be able to
stay with her if
if everything in your world is
constantly in chaos
she's going to see that at some point
right you know and this and this what
you just said about courtship you know
this but you know
like i discovered courtship in these
little tiny poison frogs that i studied
right like you know courtship has a role
to play
across any any sexually reproducing
organism
in which there is going to be parental
care by both players
right so given that and given that there
are physiological changes that accompany
the state of mind that result in
extended courtship
in other words a person in love is in a
physiologically
different state right that physiological
difference
state we now know has chemical
signatures so
could those chemical signatures be used
to
imprint the careful imprint i mean print
isn't quite what you
no i think i do mean imprint in other
words if a male
is going to produce during his lifetime
two different kinds of sperm
right those that accompany a
fleeting relationship in which he
intends to invest nothing and therefore
his interests are
in that offspring taking as much
resources it can safely get from the
mother and not saving any for
his his offspring's half-siblings
or a relationship in which he intends to
invest in which case his
interests are very symmetrical with hers
then the point is the presence or
absence of those chemicals that come
along with
uh with love could be
uh used to basically turn
on and off different genes right just
the same way
the whole argument i think it's not
exactly imprinting but like a tag like a
like a vasopressin mediated epigenetic
tag there you go
on sperm uh that indicate
you know in love or not right now i
would argue this is
an exact analog for what we imagine
happens in the case where a gene just
simply decides whether it comes from the
male parent or the female
parent right which is the usual meaning
of imprinting right
so anyway whether or not it's separate
from the other meaning that most people
have even printing of like
the duck sees conrad lorenz imprints on
him as his mom yep
yep um so anyway proof of concept
it's very easy to build a system that
can recognize these things and
and uh react differently without
changing the underlying genetic
sequences is the point
yeah cool i like it
[Music]
you